citizens of the reject Nation Greg here
today all right so we got ourselves uh
this popped up in my notification Bells
from Ryan Reynolds himself and heavy
spoilers and it was an image of Ryan
Reynolds and Hugh Jackman posing and I
was like all right I'm not going to bed
don't ask me why I was up at 6 30 in the
morning but I was and I'm like I'm not
going to bed I gotta watch this excited
too no I'm not gonna wake up my main man
John right now because uh he was here
late last night I'm gonna need my main
man present for the midnight shoot of
She-Hulk tonight him and Cole will be
carrying the video speaking of which Coy
was over here like 12 hours ago he did
shoot a koi's comic corner it's all
about Deadpool three uh of course
talking about his reaction to Hugh
Jackman and then who he believes this
version of Wolverine will be everything
we know there's a whole bunch of
intricate details and I think it's like
one of the best videos he's done on the
channel so far so please go check it out
more importantly leave a like that'd be
very much appreciated all right guys
let's do this
[Music]
hi Hi how are you you have questions yes
I can't believe I had a lot of questions
I'm sure you had a lot of questions but
rest assured we're going to answer them
right now like for example how is
Wolverine alive yeah after Logan Logan
uh takes place in 2029 totally separate
thing Logan died in Logan not touching
that okay what actually happens wow in
our film is
you dicks
very people breaking this [ __ ] down oh
damn
[Laughter]
oh God
[Laughter]
this is magical this is magical
laughs
thank you Kevin feige Love You Kevin
feige thank you MCU
we're going baby this is amazing I can't
believe this is finally happening ah
it's beautiful
you know I gotta I gotta thank I gotta
thank you guys
um first off citizens of the reject
Nation because I should have mentioned
this in the last video
um yeah I got I got several text
messages asking like did you see the
Deadpool 3 uh trailer or the Deadpool
update that Ryan Reynolds released and
then on social media you know a lot of
my message requests I could see a
preview and all the previews were about
Deadpool 3 Deadpool 3 Deadpool 3 and now
one of the previews of the messages
mentioned Wolverine lead with Wolverine
so I'm sure some of you guys mentioned
Wolverine but another previews mentioned
Wolverine in there but I had the feeling
because the last time we were talking
about Deadpool 3 and Sean Levy and the
comments he's been making like this he
might be the one to pull it off I don't
know if Shawn Levin I'm sure something
more to do with Ryan Reynolds perhaps
than whatever the specific pitch is but
there was something about Sean Levy
coming on board and the way he talked
about it that made me really believe
it's possible and it might actually
happen and I just had that feeling in
the in in the air they're like yes
it's finally about to happen and then
sure enough so I'm just glad that I
didn't get the confirmation until
watching the actual video and I want to
thank you guys for not leading with that
and but still informing me that the
video was out as far as this goes
actually
part of it seems to confirm that before
I was talking about in that video that
this will probably not be the same
Wolverine in the Logan version and it's
like they wanted to at least tease that
don't worry we're not going to ruin
Logan I think it's like a good amount of
information to give That We're Not Gonna
rewrite anything regarding that it's not
going to be some Resurrection not going
to pull him out before he dies in that
film or any [ __ ] like that reborn
from a different timeline could be you
know Wolverine from a Multiverse that
doesn't matter what does it matter like
we're gonna get Hugh Jackman back
portraying Wolverine and he's done over
in so much over the years that I'm sure
a part of what makes it exciting for him
to return is to not just regurgitate
what he did with Wolverine and all those
films that he already participated in a
big part of why I imagine it'd be fun
for him to come back is hey yeah to team
up with Ryan Reynolds have Wolverine be
part of the MCU I mean this this
probably means to me that this will be
the uh you could take it because I don't
know if you take it as a confirmation
but a a sign that will that Wolverine
Hugh Jackman could participate in secret
Wars I just think that whatever Hugh
Jackman's going to do we know he's going
to deliver and I'm sure he can bring the
things that we love about his portrayal
of Wolverine to the big screen while
also bringing something different all
these years later
and man Ryan rounds are just you're just
a marketing genius marketing genius and
you know there's going to be those
breakdown people I'm friends with many
of them they're like how can we break
down what plot Clues there might be of
what they're miming and I pray to God
pray to God that when the extras come
out for Deadpool 3 the special features
or when this film's finally released
that they release you know the the
version of whatever they were presumably
improvising we can see what they were
actually saying what they were making up
and if I imagine that was all improvised
and if you're watching just a fun
pantomime guys just messing around
improvisation you know there's going to
be improvisation on set for something
like Deadpool 3. it's gonna be something
special I really just can't wait for it
and then to see the collection of the
photos at the very end of it of hey man
this is more than just Deadpool and
Wolverine coming together this is Hugh
Jackman and Ryan Reynold Fields coming
together
ah it's just so glorious glorious to
real you know 2024 might sound like it's
far away for us right now and all that
but it's really
it's really not that far before you know
it it's gonna be here I think that's
good too because I imagine that Hugh
Jackman's Gonna Wanna because he still
looks amazing you know it's it's only
it's been less than a decade since he
last played Wolverine he still looks
amazing and I imagine he's going to want
to re-bulk back up to play Wolverine and
my God he better be getting the yellow
suit in this one I hope that this
version they actually give him the
yellow suit that's like a major thing
I'm hoping for but just the fact that
we're we're actually we're getting we
already knew we were getting Deadpool of
the MCU but the fact that we're getting
both of them Deadpool and Wolverine Hugh
Jackman and Ryan Reynolds both in the
MCU at the same time where they get to
shine together and you're not worried
about because sometimes when you when
you have like a big supporting player in
one of these films you go man but it
should be their movie and I feel like
the supporting character might take the
spotlight and I've I just that's not
going to be the case this time around
we're excited for both of them to be
coming into here so yeah it's like
obviously there's more excitement for
Hugh Jackman right now because we all
thought he would you know he was he was
dying to keep declaring he was done we
all knew that Ryan Reynolds was going to
continue on Deadpool within the MCU so
this is like an updater of true addition
to it by the excitement there but I feel
like we're both we're all just so
excited for both of them to be here and
they don't really get the sense that
one's gonna outshine the other all right
guys well I'm done I'm done blabbering
on
I don't know I don't care that I was up
this late it feels this is fun I'm so
excited so happy thank you guys for
being you and thank you for being so
supportive and uh you know this [ __ ]
like this is always a great reminder of
the joy of having a YouTube channel so
thank you guys
[Music]